bueno yo creo que es muy importante
mencionar que el 26 es definitivamente
una de las más cruciales para mantener
el vivo el acuerdo de parís y los 1.5
grados
si hay dudas al respecto pero yo soy
positiva creo en el positivismo y creo
que va a ser una una conferencia de las
partes decisivas especialmente en puntos
clave como pérdidas y daños la
movilización de recursos para poder
implementar adaptación y mitigación en
los países que más son vulnerables al
cambio climático los en billones esto es
algo que debemos hablamos como sociedad
civil como ciudadanos como jóvenes hacer
un llamado para que realmente los países
se se enfoquen en adoptar estas medidas
entonces yo soy positiva creo que van a
salir cosas importantes aunque la
situación es difícil de la pandemia
quedó un resultado que pues fue como la
demora de la agenda climática global
pero esperemos que ésta
digamos entregas resultados para
mantener vivo el acorde de parís